- Welcome to London!
We're from Canada we can handle it.
Nina, don't die on your
first day in London, okay?
(upbeat music)
Day...
one.
We got off the plane.
How'd you do, Nina?
How'd you sleep?
- Slept, a couple, few hours.
- [Evan] That's not bad.
Nina's seat wasn't working properly.
Didn't go down. But they fixed it?
They had to do it manually?
- They had to do it manually.
- But you still were able to sleep?
- Yeah.
- Then we had a...
medical emergency on the plane.
They were calling for a doctor but,
nobody said yes. So
they had an ambulance...
Anyway.
We got off. We're going
to go through customs.
And then head on the Tube. The
subway in London is the Tube.
I don't think I slept, I rested.
I don't think I slept at all.
I rested.
Welcome to London!
(calming music)
How's that London air, Nina?
Feels good, actually.
A little chilly, but...
We're from Canada we can handle it.
- Ceiling's low.
- [Evan] Ceiling's low?
- Yeah.
- [Evan] Well, you're pretty low.
- No, I was thinking of you.
- Thinking of me? I'm
going to hit my head?
Actually, it does look like
I'm going to hit my head.
It's okay, it's just big enough.
England can't handle Evan.
I like the music they play.
Oh, there's a guy here that's why.
I thought they were playing
it on the sound speaker.
- McDonalds, they have chocolate McFlurry.
- [Evan] You want a chocolate McFlurry?
Are you already thinking about food, Nina?
- It's different.
- [Evan] Different food in London
and you want to go to McDonald's.
That's what I used to always do.
Anytime I went to a new city
I would go to McDonald's
and they would make fun of me.
So, inside joke.
How's the weather feel?
- Cool.
- Refreshing, huh?
Nice! Alright, time to
explore some London.
So, we officially know where we're going.
Nina's our tour guide.
- No, I don't know what I'm doing.
- I'm the tour guide.
We're going to hit, we're
going to go find our hotel
which is just past Trafalgar Square
which is one of the most
popular areas in London.
Drop off our bags, change.
A little bit on the smelly side, perhaps.
- You.
- Both of us. I think.
Oh! Nina, food. Look!
And today's going to be
our exploring and shopping
and vibrant area city day.
Once we drop our stuff off.
Let's go!
The iconic British telephone booth.
I wonder how much longer
they're going to be around.
You guys spot the Canada flag?
Can you see the Canada flag?
Here's a clue.
Boom. Look at that. Canadian
Embassy, straight ahead.
We're not going there though,
we're going to get our hotel.
Nina's discovered some food.
What do you want to eat?
- Lemon tart.
- [Evan] You want to eat all of that Nina?
Remember, we're going on a cruise ship.
- [Nina] Yeah.
- [Evan] You're going to have
tons of food on the cruise ship.
Alright, we made it in.
We got to unpack, we got to
get rid of this heavy bag.
Oh, yeah! That feels good!
- Your back is sweating.
- I've been carrying lots of stuff.
It's only home for one day.
We leave tomorrow for the cruise.
We got to make the most of today.
Get changed and hustle,
Nina. Are you ready?
- Mmhmm.
- High five? Oh, okay good.
I thought she was going
to leave me hanging.
She almost left me
hanging. I love you Nina.
You guys know when I travel,
you know when I travel
I need to find CNN. Where's CNN?
Ah! Nina? We're officially on vacation.
CNN is on.
Alright, guys. It's official.
It's officially on 'cause I got the shirt.
'Cause we got the shirt.
How you feeling Nina?
- Good.
- Nina wants to hug it
out. Aww hug it out Nina.
Time to go explore. Nina wants
some food. I want some food.
I want a coffee, actually.
- Yeah, me too. I want a coffee.
- Yeah, I want a coffee. I
want a coffee and some food.
It's time to explore! We're finally here!
Nina's in a new country
and we are excited.
We're here at Trafalgar Square.
At the fountain behind us
some demonstration is happening too.
So, the Iranian protest is behind us.
And now there's a vegetarian
protest in front of us.
(crowd noise)
(police siren)
This is the place to have a protest.
(crowd chanting)
Nina, we didn't make our
way across before it,
before it started.
We didn't make our way across.
What we want to do is get to that...
there's a coffee shop on the other side.
(chuckling) I don't know that
we're going to get through this.
We're going to go through.
Nina, lead the way.
(crowd yelling)
Nina. Nina. Don't die on your
first day in London, okay?
- Your friend.
- [Protestor] My name's Jacob.
- [Evan] Jacob.
(crowd yelling)
Oh, nice! Okay, nice! Cool man!
Fan of the channel, alright.
Did he stop you?
- Yeah, he said "Nina!".
- Nina.
- He said, "What's Evan doing here?"
He's a fan of the channel,
alright. Okay, good.
Nina's a celebrity, she's recognized here.
(soft rock music)
Alright, our destination.
Let's get some coffee.
- It's strong.
- Alright, you like it strong.
So, that was the first
time Nina got stopped.
Is that the first time
you've been stopped?
- Huh, like, actually asked, "Nina?"
- Yeah. And got stopped before me.
So, Nina's kicking up her
celebrity profile here
in London. Look out friends.
Nina's on a warpath.
I got to, I got to be your bodyguard.
Ooh, yum. I like it. Alright!
Exploration continues.
The chaos is pretty much over behind us.
The vegan festival march and
now we're going to move on.
See what we can find.
So this is the Iranian gathering.
It's a lot more peaceful than the vegans.
A lot less yelling. They're
just watching a message on TV.
Oh, look at this.
Guy's doing street art.
I don't know what they're saying but,
something about death penalty in Iran.
So, this is the place to
come to make a statement.
I feel like we need an
entrepreneur rally next.
Trafalgar Square. Entrepreneurs stand up!
(gentle guitar music)
oh, that's Shakespeare.
William Shakespeare.
Did you read Shakespeare in school?
- Yeah.
- You memorized everything?
- No, nothing.
- To be or not to be.
That is the question.
- Yeah, okay.
- [Evan] We doing a selfie now?
- It's pretty cool that
it takes it by yourself,
automatically.
- [Evan] It's what's called a selfie.
- I don't have to press a button, okay.
- [Evan] (laughing) I'm just
teasing you. We love you Nina!
Nina. Nina. We love you.
(beat boxing)
Nina, there's Chinatown. Every
big city has a Chinatown.
You curious? You want to
go? Nina wants to go, okay.
Here we go, lets hit the Chinatown.
What's special about the Golden Phoenix?
- We have a Phoenix in, um, in, um...
In Markham too.
- [Evan] Oh.
- Gerrard Street.
- [Evan] That's what we're
on. This is Gerrard street.
- That's uh, we have a
Gerrard Street in Toronto.
- [Evan] Yeah, a lot of the
streets will be similar names.
Young Street, Young Street?
I don't know, actually.
King Street, Queen Street.
(loud music)
Nice! Chinese National Anthem.
Chinese anthem.
(piano music)
We're stopping to get
some food. Nina's hungry.
The sandwich arrived. Nina is starving.
So she's not even waiting.
She kind of got hangry.
But here we go, how is it Nina?
We should leave Nina
alone for a few minutes,
let her get some food in her. That's cool.
(soft techno music)
We're going into Foyles bookstore.
We're going to see if they have
my book. Nina's already inside.
So, Foyles is the most
iconic bookstore in London.
It's been around for over 100 years.
They have six different
stories of books and gifts
and a lot of the North American stores,
the mega bookstores are
modeled after this store here.
So, I'm excited to see
if they carry my book.
(soft techno music)
Well, good news bad
news. They're sold out.
So, I guess that's a good thing.
But I wanted to see it, in the store.
So, thank you to the London
Believe Nation folk who
supported the book and sold Foyles out.
And Foyles, let's get going on a re-order.
I want to come and sign some
books and take some pictures
and put it in the vlog next time.
Alright, Nina and I
continue on with the day.
(gentle guitar music)
We are hunting for one of the most famous
fish and chips places in London.
Nina wanted local food.
London has a lot of
international restaurants
but she didn't want to have Indonesian
or Indian or Japanese stuff.
She wanted something London.
So fish and chips.
That's what we're doing.
And we're off to find one
of the most famous houses
in London if we can find it.
But there's so many options here.
There's so many different restaurants.
There's so much potential.
Nina wants to eat everywhere.
- I want to eat everything.
- (laughing) Save it
for the fish and chips.
We found it. The Rock &
Sole Plaice. Mmm. Smell it.
Nina! You smell it?
Smell the fish and chips?
Alright, we're going
to go get our food on.
Here's the menu, look. Rock &
Sole Plaice? It's spelt weird.
Original fish and chips.
- [Nina] I saw the fish.
- [Evan] Authentic fish. I don't know.
Mushy peas, look at that. Hot
mushy peas. Sounds amazing.
We only fry in the highest
quality Groundnut oil.
What's Groundnut oil, Nina?
Nina? She's lost in the menu.
Okay, we're starting off with
some Efes Draft beer from
Turkey 'cause the London
one they had was super dark
and we don't really like dark beer.
- [Nina] Oh, here let me pour it for you.
You're going to make a lot of
bubbles. Okay, here let me do it.
You have to learn how to do this.
- [Evan] Yeah, well, try
doing it with one hand.
- [Nina] And then you turn it--
- [Evan] (chuckling) Thank you. (laughing)
- [Nina] That's how you're
supposed to pour beer.
- [Evan] Okay, let's try it.
Let's try it. Let's try it.
Oh, that's good. I like it.
We're starting with the
starter. We got, what is that?
- [Nina] Calamari and jumbo shrimp.
- [Evan] And? What's the third thing?
- [Nina] There's no, oh! Spring roll.
- [Evan] Spring roll?
- Looks like spring roll.
But I don't know.
- [Evan] Try One. Just dip it and bite.
It's okay?
- Mmhmm.
- [Evan] Alright. And
this is what we came for.
The fish and chips.
We got some cod, some chips, tartar sacue?
Dill sauce? Tartar sauce, I
guess. My mouth is watering.
- Potato wedges.
- [Evan] It's called a chip. It's a chip.
I need some good ketchup on my chips.
Good, I like it. It's cod time.
This is it. Moment of truth.
Why we came here.
Yeah, look at that white meat in there.
Mmm yum yum yum yum yum.
K, there it goes. And in it goes.
And it's hot. Ooh! It's hot.
- Mmm it's good. The fish is juicy.
- Nice! Alright, high
five. Good place. Boom.
So they've been doing this since 1871.
How you doing, Nina?
- Good.
- [Evan] Full?
- Yeah.
- [Evan] Nina's very full.
I'm ready to sleep.
- [Evan] Ready to sleep. She's
chillin back on the bench.
She left me all the fries to eat
but she's going to finish her beer.
The pigeon keeps stalking
us. He likes you.
He's like, Nina feed me food.
Nina.
- huh?
- [Evan] Feed me food.
The pigeon.
- Feed the Evan first.
- [Evan] Alright, I'm
still finishing the fries
but dessert came.
Sticky toffee with ice cream
and caramel sauce and Nina's
going to give it a shot.
Come on Nina.
Yeah?
- That's good.
- [Evan] Am I going to have any
left when I finish my fries?
- Maybe.
- Okay, we're done eating. I am so full.
That brownie thing was amazing,
the toffee pudding, whatever?
- Yeah, it's good.
- And then the beer and
the fries, it was good.
I'm feeling full.
- I'm full.
We're going to walk back to the hotel.
I feel like I need a good
walk. Got to walk it off.
Got to walk it off. Not used
to eating this much food.
Shawn has us on this--
- [Nina] Restricted diet.
- Stricted, strict diet.
Which did not include any of this food.
(laughing)
None of this food
included so it feels good
and it feels terrible at the same time.
But our stomachs I think
are going to stretch
at the end of this.
So, we're going to find
our way back to the hotel.
Here we go.
Nina misses Timo.
Nina misses Timo. Every
dog she's seen she's...
Every dog she's seen she says is cute.
Look at her smile here. There's a smile.
Look at the big Nina smile. You miss Timo.
It's only been one day, ya know.
It hasn't even been 24 hours.
It's okay. It's Nina love.
It's all Nina love.
(upbeat music)
We decided to buy some snacks
just in case we got hungry
even though our faces are full
and our stomachs are insanely crunched
we decided that we need
some snacks just in case.
So we bought Candy
Kittens Wild Strawberry,
Sour Watermelon gourmet candies.
Some pringles, sour cream and onion
and cheese and onion and then two...
What is that? Spicy lobster noodles...
And?
Chicken abalone. I don't
like the chicken abalone.
- It's just a flavor.
- [Evan] Alright.
- You won't like it, trust me.
- [Evan] Tomorrow we get on
the cruise ship so we got to
eat all this before tomorrow.
What do you think Nina?
(laughing)
- We didn't have forks.
- [Evan] Maybe. What?
- [Evan] We don't have forks.
- Yeah, we don't have forks.
Oh, just go in here and get it.
- [Evan] Where?
- Pret A Manger. Alright.
Nina's going to get some forks.
(bells chiming)
Alright, so it is the end of day one--
- Officially for us.
Yesterday was day zero.
Thank you guys for joining us.
The sun is setting on London.
We made it, we made it. Jet lag is decent.
We're going to go to the
hotel shower, cleanup,
maybe have some noodles,
watch some Agents of Shield,
go to bed and get ready
tomorrow to wake up
and go on the cruise.
What was the highlight of the day?
- I got stopped. (laughing)
- You got stopped?
You got stopped on the
street and say "Hey Nina".
(laughing) You're a celebrity?
We need to get Nina Carmichael
shirts now just for Nina.
Guys, if you're watching, if
you ever see Nina on the street
make sure you say hi because
we flew here to London
and the highlight was that
somebody stopped her on the street.
So, I feel like we can make that happen
in multiple places now just for Nina.
Thank you guys for watching.
Have an amazing weekend.
Continue to believe in
whatever your one word is.
Much love! We'll see you soon!